all right here we go i'm gonna start
this off i'm gonna say some things okay
before we get into it go ahead all right
go ahead number one yeah we ain't
talking about sandals
we are not talking about we are not
hey
i will not spend another episode
don't start talking about because you're
getting me out
don't get done listen i don't have the
best fashion and i can highly admit that
yeah these shoes what 70 bucks okay got
oranges actually like this and i
appreciate that i wear high white socks
why you keep it simple i keep it very
simple yeah but if i hear you talk about
the importance of it cured my feet and
i'm a bit of a convert and i'll be
honest with you i'm a bit religious
about it there i say you're so religious
about it i know i want to buy into the
company it drives me crazy i want to buy
in oh like this guy loves these dales
alligators snakes anacondas
trying to buy a piece of the company
what else can you not talk about oh you
can you can't uh birds
no no no uh you only did birds once why
are you sensitive and you're laughing
on my last day because i want to have
fun on my last day
did y'all have fun last night i had fun
but i didn't like it i was like
i'm sitting here like but people like us
together
they do oh yeah like they do really
well that's sweet do you know that you
don't know no listen
[ __ ] load of love you get a lot of love
do i i swear to god
i mean listen i talked i was talking
about this earlier on my podcast
rappel's world uh
[Laughter]
come see me san diego mike drop comedy
club uh this weekend friday saturday
i'm pulling you no don't see him where
are you um it's a nuke it's opening uh
grand opening of the comedy club uh in
san diego called mike drop comedy club
you know casey currier yeah his club if
you're anywhere near jersey though and
you want to see joey diaz
joey diaz and brian go to new brunswick
go to the stress factory that's all yeah
may 5th
7th and if you're anywhere near
washington d.c the next weekend the dc
comedy law
may 12 13 14 i might have a special
guest great comedy scene in dc oh yeah
by the way you might have a special
guest there
hey guys real quick there's also my
special brea brand perhaps still some
tickets left may 19th there's also a
show coming up may 17th on a tuesday and
i'll be there yeah brian's gonna be
there little brown chapelle mad peaceful
me mark harley a bunch of people
may 17th um
yeah back to centering you yeah uh
no no no what else was i telling you no
no no no you can't talk about birds uh
because you
you discredited the fact that i wanted
to fly like a bird but anyways
people like that yeah they love you
who doesn't like no because i listen you
get this ever did you get and do you
even get one
no it's very rare but when i do
i notice it i see it
but but the hate is like okay
initially
when i came onto this podcast
i knew i was going to get hate i i
initially knew because because here's
the thing
i had i had to
not fulfill your shoes or anything i
just had to come and do a position of
someone that
like podcasting is a cult
like people that like podcasting they're
like cult followers yeah and they love
you
die hard you so think about me coming i
talk about birds
and flip-flops but keep going
think about
no you did it you filled some that's
hard and you did it it is very hard but
but i initially knew i i think i
held my weight you did it you know
i was um held my weight mentally
100 as best as i it's better because you
because you don't have an ego one of my
favorite things about you yeah
it's hard it's hard for me to have an
ego why
it's just because i i guess uh it's your
best quality
did to not have an ego
yeah like you know you're you're um i
think it comes from the fact that you
take care of people you like people i do
you know you know one of you know and
you know when i figured that out i
probably you know
it was after my brother passed
after my brother passed
the only thing that got me through it
was just helping people so most people
most people don't know this wow wow so i
had got a for his
uh life insurance he made me the
beneficiary
and i got 75 grand
uh
of 75 grand right
i hated having that money wow hated it
why because like
every time i look at my bank account i
saw 75 grand i was just like this sucks
yeah yeah because
it reminded me of my brother and the way
i got that money and then i thought to
myself i was like you know what i can
get 75 grand again but i can't get my
brother back so what i did
anytime just like any time someone said
anything about needing help with
something
i just did that
wow i just gave people it
that's what i did wow i lost it and i
pretty much got rid of all that
all that money same way some people
think i'm crazy sometimes i don't think
it's crazy you're crazy at all you know
i'm not i'm not saying you do but some
people might think it's like it doesn't
surprise me because that's the kind of
person you are but that was the thing
that helped me
you know that was only that was the only
way i was able to like that's amazing
able to pick myself back up again
because i started to
it almost in a sense helps you drop this
kind of uh
it's a sense of ego the ego in the sense
of yes i was grieving
but also i was me me me me me me
does that make sense
well you're speaking with a lot of
wisdom right now am i yes am i pulling
to brian callum
well maybe more than that you know i
think that what you just said sounds
simple but very profound and and what
you said is that by giving you know what
got you out of it is giving to other
people taking care of other people and i
think that's profound and i think it's
also got religious connotations and i
think that um it's kind of what a lot of
religions talk about yeah but you know
the way you're talking is is uh
i mean you just that's a leap of faith
dude that's 75 is a lot of [ __ ] money
a lot of to to a valet i mean you were a
valet
and then it was a lot of money and yet
you spent it helping people just anybody
isn't it weird how it empowered but i
didn't but but the thing was brian damn
i it wasn't like my intention that was
never my intention
to do that i think i just
i was just so down and out that i was
just like it felt good here no it was
just like here's this yeah
here oh you need you need help with
something i i guess i was so downright
trained
in the world a little less hardship in
the world i don't i'm trying i'm trying
to figure out what exactly what it was
because it just i feel like it was very
organic
but
you know
i was able to take the lesson from it
because i because i thought back on it i
was like man
i was like what was that
and then i started to realize i was like
oh i was helping other people and
watching these other people
you know
i guess be happy in a sense that and i
was like oh i
and then i started to realize oh i was
like oh i i made you happy and it made
you feel good about yeah
does that make sense very much so but
you know the other quality you have that
i think is has to be talked about is
when you tell me you spent 75 grand that
that story most people who if that most
people said i did that i would go
i'd go like this in my head i'd go
15 grand
you know what i mean like in my head
not really but i like the story i
believe
i believe 100 of everything you said
i believe 100 of everything you say all
the time because that's that's your gift
too
it's like you just don't lie you don't
[ __ ] yeah here's what i also else i
like about you
this is the other thing since it's our
last day
you and i pretend to box and you ask me
questions about boxing mm-hmm and then i
do this thing and you go oh what the
[ __ ] you know yeah
uh
you're a much better athlete you were
crushing brennan in that race by the way
nobody knows you were beating him in
that race i know what i was doing
crushing him in that race before he
played brendan
it was about a thousand dollars
much stronger much bigger and younger so
you know if you learned
for a couple months you'd
knock my [ __ ] head off but it's great
because you go like this oh man because
you're giving me i don't know that world
yeah but you're giving me respect i
don't know that welder and you're just
taking care of me what you're doing
there is you're actually taking care of
me okay whether you know it or not
you're taking care of me yeah you're
you're letting me teach you something
and then you're
you're going whoa you know
you're taking care of me and i do that
to people so i appreciate that oh so
anyway
you're gonna get more and more
successful don't lose any of that [ __ ]
don't lose any of that stay exactly the
guy who gives 75 thousand dollars away
if you do that in my humble opinion i
believe that it will lead you to the
promised land
and what is the promised land i don't
know
but you'll know it show them that way
you know what the next 75 grand i make
i'll invest
into those in my company
no i would never i'm going to make a
fortune i would have that'd be the last
thing i'd give it to it's the [ __ ] i
guess you hate money
i guess you hate giving back to animals
in africa i don't know you don't like
you don't how about giving back to
animals do you guys use them to you make
it animals i like how you're talking i
guess you you what are you talking about
how you hate elephants oh okay you don't
have elephants how's that helping
elephants
well i mean we have an exotic leathers
uh thing that we do
we i'm not even
they're already dead and you guys just
get them in like hey and actually what
what people do recycling what people
don't realize about africa is that when
you have a game reserve and you have a
lot of elephants yeah let's just take
elephants because everybody loves
elephants right yeah so if i were to say
hey you want some elephant skin
flip-flops you'd be like [ __ ] you right
yeah
wearing elephant skin until you realize
that with elephants because they're hurt
animals the older ones the ones that get
sick or the or
or they breed too much so the the land
cannot support them because they'll
start tearing down all the vegetation so
the truth is to keep healthy elephant
populations migrating and stuff they
actually kill they cull them because
when you have to sterilize them it's
really expensive and hard so the truth
is if they're whale too old to breed or
they're way too old they will either
issue a very expensive hunting tag yeah
so you can do that with rhinos so if you
want to hunt a rhino that's really old
and not breeding anymore it'll cost you
350 000
you get to kill the rhino right
and then you get but what but that money
goes directly to the wardens to the
rangers and to the game reserve okay so
when it's all it's all controlled all of
it yeah so so with with toehold when
they get um
i can't judge the situation because yeah
so if you're wearing like because
are you are you going are you going nope
but i said i said i looked at these
elephant skin flip-flops and i was like
whoa oh bro because you know if i'm
going to buy into a company yeah you
know i want to i can't do that uh-huh
and so
when you when you when they take that
skin off an elephant they take the meat
if you can harvest it and they give it
to the village in new york okay then you
take the skin
and you sell that skin
and there are all these government
regulations it's [ __ ] crazy you sell
that skin to a licensed tannery or a
skin dealer in the united states
they take that when they take that skin
and sell it
that money goes back to the [ __ ]
when they sell it to the wholesaler that
money goes right back to the the gamers
let's take a break brian
yeah let's take a good break now now i'm
going to be at the stress factor this
weekend with joey diaz do you come see
me there i'm going to be at the uh
comedy loft in dc the following weekend
and i'm shooting my special
may 19th at the improv yes you are uh
what are you where are you going to be
about uh may 6th and 7th uh this coming
weekend i will be in san diego at mic
drop comedy club and then uh
may 12th i'll be in phoenix
at stand up live and then later in the
summer uh june 24th the 25th i'll be in
rhode island at the comedy connection
all right well listen life can be
overwhelming it can be it can be kind of
tough we take care of our bodies and
everything else but people never take
care of your mind your mind sometimes
you have a lack of motivation you feel
helpless trapped detached
tired yup
and that happens to all of us and you
don't have anybody to talk to i always
talk about how guys don't a lot of times
have other guys to talk about in my case
and we need to talk you do or you just
got to have somebody who can listen and
everybody's too busy
better help
is customized
online therapy it offers video phone
even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to
but it's there
it's way more affordable than in-person
therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
another 48 hours
this is an actually amazing this is one
of the great things about the internet
yeah because you know people can't
afford to drive there they can't afford
to go there they don't want to go there
they don't want to sit in a waiting room
fighter and kid listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com fighter that's better
h-e-l-p dot-com
fighter
look man nobody likes waiting for a
paycheck waiting on a paycheck
especially when you got bills due that's
chime though chime c-h-i-m-e
you get your paycheck up to two days
early with direct deposit
that's two more days to save pay bills
or just feel good about your money
situation chime is more than just about
getting paid early as well it's an
award-winning mobile app checking
account
debit card an optional savings account
gotta save so chime can help you with
that
so if you get a if you get a paycheck
whatever it is get started with chime
today applying for a free account takes
less than two minutes do you have two
minutes yeah two minutes get started on
chime c-h-i-m-e dot com slash fighter
that's chime
dot com slash fighter
banking services and debt card provided
by the bancorp bank that's very
important or stride bank because i know
you guys were wondering
comma n.a i know this is very important
members fdic which means it's guaranteed
by the federal government early access
to direct deposit funds depends on payer
you know what i didn't realize i watched
this video clip on it i just type in
planet earth [ __ ] all the [ __ ] i do
too uh because it's so interesting
because i'm like man we don't live like
that
but
i watched this video on this elephant it
had passed away
uh i think i don't know if a guy got
sick eventually just died and they
talked about the importance
of the animals like hyenas or lions
coming in
to pretty much
eat all that yeah because if they if
like if they don't
i guess it's like really bad for the
earth
yes and no but yeah yeah in some sense
it's all it's all an ecosystem yeah like
something that yeah where it would just
be really bad if that bot that
elephant's body just
sat there
as is yeah right yes am i crazy yes you
are no you're right okay the problem is
that when you have um so when you have a
game reserve so in south africa they
take what used to be cattle ranches
and then they they fence them off and
now you own a game reserve and now you
say and you put up a lodge and you go
you guys want to see animals in the wild
come on by these animals they're not
really in the water not really well
they're on a game they're on what used
to be so all those cattle they're taking
pictures of and all that [ __ ] mostly
that krueger national park is a little
bit different because kruger national
park is the one that i always see like
whenever i look on youtube that's an
area of the size of like israel bring up
kruger national park is [ __ ] huge but
that that area is where they have delta
force guys stopping people from poaching
rhinos and all that [ __ ] but it's a
really big area right seven thousand
five hundred twenty three miles because
that was a reserve that was set apart oh
[ __ ] yeah cougar packs park bigger than
england look at that
it's [ __ ] crazy right
but most of the places and by the way
it's so crowded with cars it's so crazy
crowded that the animals are like oh boy
they're just used to it huh yeah the
animal's like oh [ __ ] here comes another
jeep like there are lines of jeeps all
right hey question who's got a who's got
a harder bite
hyena or lion hyena how'd you know that
heinous can crack uh uh
bones yeah hippo bones did you know that
no none of you guys knew that
read a book
read a book i got that you watched a
video oh yeah
[Laughter]
all right that's fair okay you win that
round you win that round you win that
round
no but it is always because here's the
problem so now you got a game reserve
and you got it you buy animals and you
put them on there so you put elephants
on you put giraffes on there you put
water buffalo on there you put gazelles
you put kudu you put all that stuff
um then you want but people want to see
lions
they want to see a pride of mother the
big cat yeah they want to see cheetah
they want to see leopards they want to
see these things okay wait are the big
cats are lions the only ones that roll
together yeah they're pride they're
there well cheetahs roll
sometimes unpairs and then the kids are
there but yeah for the most part lions
are are they running we're probably
driving fans crazy right now they're
like [ __ ] a pack right uh-huh no no
here's what people don't know when you
have when you have a [ __ ] when you
have a game reserve and you got lions on
there
you can't afford it because the lions
are going to kill
all your other animals so you got to
keep restocking with giraffes water
buffalos
all that [ __ ] because they will [ __ ]
and oh by the way you might not have
leopards you got leopards leopards find
their way in yeah then you got cerebrals
you got all kinds of leopards are the
ones that are kind of like look like
lone rangers yeah yeah you got cats all
different kinds of cats too and the cats
come in and [ __ ] things up so if you
gotta hurt a zebra it starts to cost you
crazy money so lions are the lions
they're too good at hunting they're too
good at killing the females the best oh
dude they're so are the males though no
the the female is better than yeah but
there are four hours at night when the
males are like i'm coming
really oh yeah
they just think only females hunted yeah
then they had these knight cameras and
they were like yeah they lay around for
20 hours that four hours holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude there's this video i don't
know how true it is there's this video i
watched of this lion
[ __ ] up these hyenas
because i think
it came through a hyena came over and
like
killed sworn enemies yeah and so the the
male lion went out and [ __ ] yeah bro
hunted these [ __ ] and got
revenge yes so so that's how true that
video it is true there's like it's it's
called it's called they called him itwa
du mela
and andy yeah
the tanzanians called him this male lion
so all these hyenas are killing they're
killing they're ganging up on this
female they're killing her right you got
to put a caption right there
and the male lion hears it going on
and you just see and i think it was
powers booth who was [ __ ] narrating
it you just see shout out to powers
and it says in swahili this means one
who greets with fire
yeah
oh you found it no one who greets one
who greets with fire one who greets with
fire and you just see this [ __ ] lion
and he goes he
is the hiding king
and you see this [ __ ] it's kind
of weird and all the hyenas run
all of them are like ah
and he catches one and breaks its back
and then okay oh this yeah there it is
watch this one if we're allowed to but
let's watch that
watch it yeah just edit it out
go to this
the day belongs to the lion ryan there's
a
i watched too many of these [ __ ]
videos there was this one where it was
one lion and it should load a hyenas
yeah male lion and it was like you know
it was number female or is it a male it
was a male line sure yeah it was
outnumbered
and then another male lion comes over
they [ __ ] book it oh yeah and it was
just and it was still outnumbered even
though it was two lions yeah but two
male lions
can [ __ ] rock that rock
swim in the water with crocodiles and
growl at them really yeah they're just
like
you know in the crocodile i don't know
what irons are swimming now they swim i
thought i knew tigers did and jaguar the
jaguar yeah
yeah
jaguars are essentially aquatic cats the
aguard
the jaguar is
for me it's the strongest
because for me it's one you need 300
pounds yes
and they carry they carry their food up
into a [ __ ] church yes they're coming
they're crazy okay man yeah they are
they are that's that that's that [ __ ] i
love watching those damn videos and i
like to find like
the crazy like nature's metal on
instagram me too dude sign me the [ __ ]
up how about that chimpanzee that was
bashing that [ __ ] seagull to death
yeah caught a seagull and was just gone
i don't know if it's a champ but it was
a monkey i'm just bashing its [ __ ]
but you know what's crazy like oh no you
know what's crazy about it all right is
all they're doing is just trying to eat
that's right
at the end of the day
these [ __ ] just trying to eat
that's an exception that's what's
[ __ ] crazy about it and people look
at it as go oh they're evil and it's
like no [ __ ] i'm hungry there's an
exception in goma in goma and uh
yeah i know you get me started there's
an exception why did i why did i get one
this is my last episode
uh i said the french way the chimpanzee
because they're so human they're the
only animal that we know of they might
be with dolphins too but they're the
only animal we know of that actually
was going into other territories and
other bands of chimpanzees killing the
males
and
territory then and taking the females
and babies as their own
very human
killing them oh yeah so young young
males would patrol
their their line of territory okay and
then they'd catch other males from the
other bands alone or two at a time just
kind of out there foraging and kill them
and and then they would expand their
territory how about looking crazy how
about that [ __ ]
yeah that wait they're they're basically
jumping from territory to terrorism
human human [ __ ] our ancestors
our ancestors the chimpanzee the
chimpanzee
let's see if you guys have a good memory
one animal because oh no what animal can
see a snake better than any other animal
in the in the wild eagle tiger no eagle
eagles
yeah but
is it the eagle it has to be the eagle
because you ever seen the eagle plug and
catch a snake they dampened their eyes
they have better eyes than anybody but
humans
humans
humans oh weakest yeah that's oh yeah
okay
man
why did you do that
why'd you make it like that he loves
questions like that like you should you
should have been like besides besides
humans
who could see us think better
i like
i like asking questions oh you i mean
listen since brenda's been gone he's
been having a [ __ ] world with asking
these [ __ ] but people like these
girls they like you
uh are you excited about your your
independence your new move yeah my
independence like i was a slave what are
you gonna
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i said that
and you're right
you're right
but i know it's hard breaking away
but i know it's heartbreaking away you
felt bad
right and you were like [ __ ]
no
i'm sorry
you're independent you excited where
you're going to be racist
delete that's so funny
[ __ ] that's all i need
i know right racist like no
we're clicking this no i just had to
throw it at you
it was a fun jab i deserved it are you
excited for your independence i [ __ ]
deserved it
but you you're going off on your own i i
you're truly podcast i truly am uh but
you should by the way i just yeah i
don't know man it's just
doing the things like i get to do
just is i mean headlining
is so [ __ ] fun it's where you belong
headlining like there's nothing better
is there anything better like like
listen i love brandon brennan thank you
for letting me feature for you but man i
am bored
featuring you need an app it's just
something about yeah an hour where you
work you're telling your story
you have to like have
and i guess i get excited for headlining
because i look at it i'm like oh this is
a new thing to learn yeah this is like
this thing like like i love to learn
something new and i want to learn
something obviously within
you know
the thing i love to do
if i get to learn a new thing yeah hell
yeah that keep that just keeps the
excitement going and it makes me expand
my brain even more wanting to
look at these certain areas i mean a lot
of the stuff that i talk about on stage
all of it has to do with me
you know and a lot of it is just like
reflective over the years of things that
i've gone through and i've taken those
i've taken these like traumatic things
and made them just goofy yeah because
i've learned to be okay with all of it
you know what i mean so so to talk about
it the way that i i am able to talk
about it is so [ __ ] dope mm-hmm okay
like that that to me
are you gonna see this special who are
you gonna see your special um
not yet i want to headline like i wanted
like a
consistent strong smart headlining tour
before i just take your i have no reason
to [ __ ] put one out right now i
always say that i want it what's the
russian special take your time i want it
to be something
obviously that i'm really proud of
because i'm very critical of myself i've
been recording my sets and i've been
watching back and uh
just to to be able to go i could have
done that better if i just say this this
and apply that and then put that out
there on the stage and watch it and you
see the result of what you yeah what
you've studied and you might by the way
is [ __ ] my experience last three
weeks if you're like before you shoot
your special you may change a shitload
because you'll start going [ __ ] like
can i get deeper on this you know yeah
yeah yeah you're crazy no that makes
sense that's what i did yeah i did like
a eight minute set um or nine minutes
step for don't tell comedy those uh
secret shows you know don't tell comment
i think you've got some but uh they they
started you know applying this thing
where they film
uh comedian sets especially comedians
that are up and coming that are really
good that no one may really know about
but they're really good and it's like
hey let's give them a chance it's kind
of like what
late night yeah you know how late night
was the thing if you got on late night
it was it was that you know i guess
not guess but living in this world of uh
social media where everything's social
media heavy
and it's like hey why don't we just do
this thing where we make this platform
and help you know put comedians out
there so it was cool to see myself in a
on
tape on film like that yeah you know it
was like you know beautiful beautifully
produced
different cameras and just the only
difference is like you got one shot
where's like a special you got two shots
so you kind of kind of
you know go with your
your best but
even seeing that i love that i actually
did it and i didn't want to do it at
first i didn't want to film i said i'm
like man i want to put something out
there that's like it's like you know
what actually do this just it's it's
it's eight minutes in comparison to what
you're going to do
in a headlining set
you know so eight minutes is like just
put it out there a lot of the jokes that
i had that i did are the jokes that i'll
continue to do because i
had to convince them to to fit the eight
minutes yeah but uh it was do you get
worried about
like what you're gonna do next like do
you get worried about the next hour do
you ever have that anxiety no because
i'm still building an hour hour yeah you
know that's the oh yeah the second video
is the look at me just being big on
stage comfortable and smiling and [ __ ]
uh
but yeah it was it was really really
cool but uh
no i haven't done an hour yet but it is
exciting to
i remember when i would i remember when
i first
after jfl i got my first my agents right
and they were like hey you got to offer
for a headlining gig i told him i said
hey
i have 30 minutes okay i was like i
could stretch to a 45 but i was like i i
really want to get
at least a solid 45
to where you know comfortable but
obviously you know if the offers are
coming in
you know you know do you consider
yourself an intelligent person
honestly be honest
in the sin uh
i don't know a lot of [ __ ]
that's not what i ask uh i know a lot
that has nothing to do with intelligence
yeah absolutely that's fair um it has
zero that's like um i know a lot of [ __ ]
and it means it it just means i had more
stuff put in my ear well that's what i'm
saying like the intelligent thing i'm
trying to i went looking yeah
well i don't know because i feel like
you're
don't quantify it you're very
intelligent you need to know that i hope
you know that i i'm not wrong and i'm
not and it's not an opinion it's a fact
you're a very intelligent guy and
you're very self-aware and you're very
aware you're just [ __ ] talking about
i need more time a half hour like that
that shit's that shit's being very
self-aware and intelligent and so a lot
of people think that they're not that
intelligent or that you know all that
stuff you're
you know you're
very curious
you know you're very interested in what
you don't know hold on
i'm gonna need more of that out of you
guys
whoa you're very interested in what you
don't know and i'll say and i'll say
this and that's my definition
and this is why uh like i said that
while when i first signed with
my brother say hey i only have 30
minutes i could stretch to a 45 but i
have a strong 30 minutes i was like i
want to get you know
and i say that because
my favorite comedians
right patrice o'neill
i love patrice o'neill i love eddie
murphy i love bill burr i love daniel
taj all these comedians that i highly
admire
and
to see what they do
in an hour
is [ __ ] amazing to me and i'm like i
want to eventually get to that
but but
you know that's why i told my agents
like i i'd like i look up to these like
people that are like that's great north
stars to me yeah
you know so
i don't want to like disrespect the fact
that i look up to them or like i want to
do that justice it's like if i look up
to these people
i kind of have to deliver this thing
every time if that makes any sense david
tell you when i sat down with paris
o'neil the only time i really actually
spent time with him i was with dove
davidoff uh-huh can't remember we might
have been at the comedy cellar i don't
know and he started talking about
relationships and women and and
acquainted with karate how they show you
their karate you show you show them your
karate
and now i'm
i don't know i know he is but i also
came up with him so yeah yeah i i
performed with him in new york but i
didn't you know
and uh
because his fame came almost after you
know yeah and uh
and i was just listening to him and i
was in my i was probably in my 40s and i
went i looked at dove i went this [ __ ]
is heavy and dove goes the man drops a
heavy truth
it drops a heavy truth
i don't remember this a lot of the stuff
i do remember a lot of stuff he said but
it was so [ __ ] profound profound and
and so metaphorical it was so [ __ ]
good and i was like this dude's just
telling me this right now because i
brought something up and he's dropping
this kind of wisdom mm-hmm it's like
this should be a [ __ ] ted talk yeah
it should be
crazy what's crazy about patrice that
people don't realize because i watch
people try to do
what he did but there was a level of
intelligence within himself that he
understood
and i think that's why he was able to
deliver
what he was able to deliver on stage and
i don't think a lot of people are really
tapped in with themselves
that strongly to be able to do what he
does that's why i watch so many people
try to do it
and i'm like oh you're not
you're just trying to say it because
patrice would say it
and
you're but you're not tapped in with
yourself
you know
emotionally or anything like that and
and he was he that's why he would say
the things he would say and he said
something that i'll never get he goes he
goes man i he goes if if i'm not honest
with myself
he goes then i don't want to i don't
want to walk i don't want i don't want
to go
do anything he goes i have to be honest
it's like that thing where um tim
robbins one time i don't know if you
know he is but he he did this movie
called dead man walking with sean penn
and he uh he had eddie vetter do the
music springsteen do the music
show me tim roberts
the um dead man walking the soundtrack
is [ __ ] amazing oh you got to see
that movie oh tim roberts oh gee yeah
yeah yeah ot a bad [ __ ] yeah
sean penn one one of sean penn at his
best like well like he won an oscar i
think oh [ __ ] or almost like he he this
was him at his best this is when sean
penn was like
[ __ ] unbelievable unbelievable i mean
unbelievable right and um
and i mean he was so good in this i got
to rewatch this and susan sarandon this
is [ __ ] old [ __ ]
based on a true story by the way
and uh
you know tim robbins wanted music and he
chose artists he said i didn't want an
artist i didn't want a musician who uses
tricks and hooks
i wanted i wanted musicians to tell
stories you know
at all at all costs yeah
and that's a good soundtrack but i never
forgot that and i thought to myself as a
comic i'm using a lot of tricks and
hooks
you know but
you want to tell a story
yeah you know yeah i mean you want to
say something anyway exactly and that's
what i'm that's what i've
when it comes to like doing a special
yeah i'm like i gotta i gotta say
something yeah cause i watch so many of
them and patrice elephant in the room
is probably my top my number one i gotta
watch it great
great special but from start to finish
he is saying something and he does this
thing that's so unique well i i describe
it as this
the way he sets up his jokes because i
noticed i was like okay yeah as
comedians we already know the punch line
the audience audience doesn't we already
know the punch line you know so he takes
people through these walks
they'll take him to a park you know take
it you know do this nice little park you
know you'll see some nice things in the
park
and then when the punchline comes all of
a sudden you're at this amusement park
you're at this better thing and like he
was really good
at walking people
to this punch line because he already
knew it they don't know it but the way
he would walk people to it
was [ __ ] amazing and i appreciated
that i appreciate that about him crap
cause it's like oh it's such a it's such
a [ __ ] craft and i don't even know
how much
he even realized it yeah you know i
don't i don't know you know i've
listened to quite a few of his
interviews but he would just he could
just go
and ever like you said everything was so
profound but it was just but that that
special elephant in the room
i'm telling you from start to finish
also when i watch the special can you
look up for tracy neil and did he go to
college
i think he was a reader though he did a
lot of reading but uh
oh so he was saying things so dope
that it's hitting the audience at home
yeah like people people sitting on their
couch
are watching it
and like you could you could feel it
that's what i think is like dope and i'm
like oh man i gotta
i gotta take my time on this i just
wanna stop you
now look man
this is something some of the most
successful people i know okay physical
people yep
thoughtful people
uh take athletic greens okay
athletic greens is basically uh you get
essentially all your phytonutrients
bioflavonoids probiotics like vitamins
everything you can think of your fiber
everything in one scoop
okay one scoop of ag-1 contains 75
minerals vitamins whole food source
ingredients a multivitamin a
multi-mineral a probiotic green
superfood blend so you get all your
vegetables
more in one convenient daily
it's delicious so this works for vegans
it's yes it does it's delicious
it's it's a special blend of high
quality bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop
of ag-1 it fills in all your nutritional
gaps because you don't have time
but it supports energy supports focus my
buddy sam triply was doing a podcast
with me and he was like literally i was
like dude are you on what's going on you
on drugs he goes dude i i took athletic
greens i have so much energy it's crazy
he swears about it it works okay it does
and i know people that are very in tune
with their bodies and very successful
that take this
and they swear by it and they also the
thing about you you never know what's
going to be in a container of something
athletic greens is obsessed with making
sure that the ingredients you get in
there are really
cool there's one gram of added sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial anything okay to keep it
tasting good
so you get all kinds of people to do it
for me the endorsement was the the
people i know who are the most
successful and intelligent take it and
that's all i need to know athletic
greens is going to give you an immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first person purchase if you
visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today
visit
athleticgreens.com control your health
and give ag one a try
l
m n t pronounced element okay
is basically a way to get electrolytes
uh into your body
okay electrolytes are something you will
die with if you don't have enough
the first thing they do when you're
you know in a bad way and you've been
dehydrated or whatever is they put
electrolytes in your body you try to
balance your electrolytes okay
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything you need and nothing you
don't
lots of salt with no sugar contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligrams sodium which i don't
know you know 200 milligrams of
potassium 60 milligrams of magnesium uh
most people are low on magnesium
actually so i'm going gonna take their
word for it
uh but you got no junk no sugar no
coloring no artificial ingredients no
gluten no fillers no bs
element lmnt is formulated to help
anyone with electrolyte needs and it's
perfectly suited to follow for people
who follow keto low carb paleo diet
uh and it basically balances you another
product for everybody correct it's so
sure you'll love that product by the way
element and that it comes with
more than they are offering you a free
element sample pack lmnt that's eight
single serving packets free just cover
the cost of shipping five dollars for
use customers get your drink
element.com
okay so it's drink
lmnt.com fighter the deal is not
available on the regular website you got
to go d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
drink element dot com fighter
and uh it also offers a no questions ask
refund
try it totally risk-free if you don't
like it share it with a salty friend we
will give you your money back or they
will give you their money back no
questions asked you have nothing to lose
i love that so they're standing behind
their product try it out you ever taken
me on it you ever taken the alpha brain
i haven't i've always been intrigued by
it it's an it's a nootropic it proves
they did these double-blind studies at
the boston school of memory and it
actually improves memory and cognition
nootropics actually work and alpha brain
is i think
joe rogan kind of started experimenting
with nootropics when he saw that the
chinese military were using them okay
and then he figured out what was in him
started taking them and got obsessed and
if that's how on it was born
so alpha brain is that thing they got
alpha brain instant black label
focus shot they got stuff for your sleep
new mood they got melatonin spray and
the reason i liked i've always loved
forever i've always loved on it was
because rogan would use all of their
products
created a company and would you go to
his house and it's got he's got it all
there uses every day
uh they got joined oil they got active b
complete they got great everything they
got if you if you get vitamin d from
them if you get creatine from them you
get glutamine from them it's all you get
shroom tech support yeah and shroom tech
sport which is unbelievable it's a blend
of mushrooms that actually increases it
oxygenates your body
gives you gives you more endurance the
vitamin d spray everything they have i
promise you is going to be the best
supplements you can find on planet earth
on it.com fighter 10 off get some so i
want to just show you something patrice
lumumba malcolm
all right
you laugh but that's a really important
name you laugh and that's that's no way
i'm not laughing at the name
is a very famous african yes he was
assassinated yeah he was
yep okay so uh but i want to just i want
to just make a point uh-huh okay was
born in new york city december 1969. his
he was named by his mother after patrice
lumumba leader of the congolese
independence movement i think lumumba
was killed by the cia by the way and
republic of congo's first prime minister
and
the african-american human rights
activist malcolm x yeah he was bullied
at school over his name but later said
it taught him how to be a man he and his
sister zinder were raised by their
mother in boston's largely black
working-class roxbury neighborhood
o'neal and iran are related with his
father although he was aware of his
identity you know that neighborhood
is what is like
uh the roxbury neighborhood no i don't
okay but but
so i don't know much about him now so he
turned down a sports scholarship at
northeastern university in boston which
included a housing grant in favor of
studying performing arts at the
university with a major in theater
studies
okay
okay his interest in comedy had grown by
this time and he took up a work as a
bouncer blah blah blah now
so i'm bringing this up because patrice
o'neil
was an educated man and you know why i
know that because his mother
his mother was clearly an educator she
might have been in a poor neighborhood
his mother
understood who patrice lumumba was yes
and you can't understand who patrice
lamuma was and you can't you can't name
your son patrice lumumba
without understanding
lumumba's
historical
impact yeah you haven't really know that
yeah on the united states on the united
states legacy on on being
african-american i'm being
african-african on being black so this
woman had a strong
understanding of the significance of
that name in one way or another which
means
she was reading and reaching outside of
herself it wasn't all about her okay and
when she raised that boy alone or maybe
with son i promise you that that
that
value system that understanding of who
you are and your responsibility
as a black man in america
because malcolm x
and
patrice lumumba two people that were
assassinated for their stand for their
belief for their philosophy and for
their courage
they were assassinated by a power
structure most likely a white power
structure that had different ideas that
was not lost on that woman no
and then oh he speaks i think they speak
about that in the doc okay and she gave
thanks to his dog and i think she gave
him a [ __ ] i can't remember what book
yeah she gave her okay so patricia i
promise
and if you didn't grow up reading he
grew up understanding now you don't get
a theater degree you don't get a theater
degree like that in theater studies
without having to read all of
shakespeare
you don't get a theater degree without
having to read william inge tennessee
williams i can give you all the names
and then you don't read those plays
without having historical context for
where they were why they were when
you're playing those characters you have
to know what it is to be this and the
other thing
tennessee williams was writing about
[ __ ] and you don't you ain't getting
your [ __ ] degree back then like me
without understanding tennessee williams
william you're not understanding he's a
gay man in the south
who had to keep it a secret and what
that meant and you're not getting it
without understanding there's a
brutality in the south of brutality so
if you're a black person in certain
towns in the south you don't let the sun
come down on you because you'll die okay
all that [ __ ] is part of what patrice
o'neal grew up with and the larger point
i'm making is that if you want to be
like patrice and neal which i believe
you could be
you have to educate yourself and hold
yourself to the same standard of
education because
what gave him the father to speak that
way was the fact that this man
was
was had immersed himself
in the best that had been thought and
said 100 right 100 that's my argument
for education no no no yeah and i i
completely agree and that's what i'm
saying like when it comes to the
headlining you know
it's making me i mean you even said this
to me when when we like first when we
first met like back in arizona like
after you you saw me go up you you go
man like
you said get out of here obviously and
you but you were like
are you reading you know like what like
that that was the thing i remember the
most is when you said what are you what
are you reading what are you what are
you trying to do to expand see you know
which which i was like oh i've never
thought about that
with comedy was like what do you what
are you so important it's it's so
[ __ ] important it's important and
it's remind me
in in honestly reading the books i have
read
has has made me understand things about
myself to where i go oh my god oh [ __ ]
you know
i remember where you are why is i used
to get mad about it i used to get so you
know i used to get mad about when i was
a kid
it would it would drive me [ __ ] crazy
when people would call me white
goddamn i used to get i used to get so
mad
about that
black people would call you that in
everybody damn everybody and
you know i got it at home a lot from my
stepfather mm-hmm
wow and so
dealing with that
you know think about it like it put me
in this position
to to
when i look in the mirror
i see a black kid of course
but
to everyone
out there they're like oh
you're white i've never thought that you
know why i know i know
you and you have it but people put
people with people trying to keep you in
a box in one way or another right
exactly just it was just all based off
of finding you all based off of my
interest
you know what i mean and
you know i may
talk a certain way or whatever the case
may be but i used to get so
[ __ ] mad
about it and i would like i would i
would try to fight people over but i was
just like
eventually
i got to a point to obviously where that
fighting kind of it exhausts you
you know you get exhausted so you're
fighting you're fighting this way you
know what you only do because sometimes
you believe it yourself a little bit
right yeah exactly and that was that was
that was my thing that was my thing
and it took certain things embarrassing
when people say that too yeah because
it's like it's like oh i can't
it's like to to you like this is oh this
is who i am to you i don't have an idea
i'm wearing a costume yeah i want a
costume to you and it's like meanwhile
it's just like [ __ ] it this is i
eventually had to just say [ __ ] it this
is this is just who the [ __ ] i am and
most of those some of those people that
i still know today that used to make fun
of me about it and used to just call me
white eventually gave up because they
were like oh this guy's just been him
himself
the whole [ __ ] time you know what i
mean first of all you're a comic yeah
yeah so you're not you're you're a comic
and and that's already you're already on
the outside looking but but reading
reading helped me understand that a lot
a lot more thomas hull
um
no not that yet but it was just certain
things of uh
understanding that
at the end of the day no one can ever
define you
no matter no matter what like at the end
of the day no matter what people say
you're also imminent people can leave a
comment about you or something at the
end of the day they still don't
they they they still don't have the
right to by the way they might they
might be right today but you know who i
am today is not who i'm going to be
tomorrow exactly could be tomorrow
exactly and so
and one of the biggest things was
reconnecting with my biological father
yeah because there were certain things
he said
he didn't necessarily just like
oh you're black you know what it was it
wasn't that
it was just the sense of uh
he was showing me
relatives this is your great grandma wow
it's your great grandpa wow
but hearing that yeah you know what i
mean so like when people call me white
it's like hey i can't go back and look
at
old white people and be like yeah that's
my [ __ ] house yeah
that's my cousin
exactly like in my adoptive focus that's
not a choice and that's what i'm saying
my adoptive folks who are [ __ ] loved
to death you know to this day like i'm
still connected with them you know
they're beautiful [ __ ] people
um and i think they understood like
yeah like there's only we can give you
love
and care for you and teach you these you
know these things within
you know within range
but after at a certain point
you're going to have to seek out that's
right i think that's what one thing i
learned
from my adopters know thyself man yes
exactly because it's like hey we we
can't show you family family lineage is
that the word i'm looking for yes that's
the word yeah i'm trying to be on my
brian mode right now
you're doing great am i doing great okay
you're killing it you
they can't they can't show me that
because they don't know it
they they just know hey this kid was in
need well that was something you had
that makes sense yeah that's something
sometimes in life and i just had this
conversation with my buddies going
through some [ __ ] yeah and i and i said
uh i said the the truth is sometimes you
go through things in life you're the
only one who can get yourself out of it
only one only one holy person only when
you realize oh [ __ ] i'm alone
yeah i'm in this row boat alone i don't
see any land dude i'm telling you so
even with my brother passing yeah i was
like oh i'm a lone wolf you're alone i'm
alone in this like i get this like i
could hold your hand for a while but
exactly people can hold your hand and
all the all this [ __ ] but at the end of
the day
it's all on you yes and i don't know how
but like most people like i could sit
here when you accidentally blame so many
things no when you accept that oh it's
so funny on those situations like yeah
it's okay it's like i could sit here and
blame my abusive stepfather all day yeah
but hey guess what i don't live with him
anymore and he made him and he made
himself actually i love him
hey shout out hey shout out uh
i'll [ __ ] i'll say his name you're
not gonna find him shout out to jerry
jerry who was going through his own [ __ ]
maybe that's what
guess what guess what about jerry guess
what
he didn't know his father
there you go
and to this day it still eats him up of
course it does you know of course it
does but but he's wounded but man to be
able to [ __ ]
you know take that take
take the i don't even know if he really
i don't even know if he really had my
power but it made you more competitive
for a second he had my actually he did
but it made you more compassionate
yes right it made you more compassionate
even for him
yes you get older and all of a sudden
you're like yeah cause it's like what do
you what do you want me to do well it
made you what are you doing what can we
do other than
move forward well because i was like we
can butcher this situation all day yeah
but your job is my opinion
listen this is for anybody this is what
freed me your job is to to
orchestrate your life in such a way that
you
get to a point
the goal is to get to a point where you
write jerry a letter whether you send it
or not
thanking him yeah
thanking him
for being the angel or the demon that
pushed you to your best self
like that is so important i don't give a
[ __ ] who did what to you yeah
and yeah guess what i'm wasting time no
no one does no no one really wastes time
it's just chaos yeah it's just chaos man
dude that took a form of humans
yeah chaos is what's going to push me to
my best self yeah yeah you know because
here's the thing alone this is when i
realized no one gave gave a [ __ ]
as i was becoming an adult
and i was holding that baggage
of my stepfather and you know that whole
situation and as i was
like i said as i was growing to be an
adult
and
i'm now i'm going into
jobs i'm going into schools all of my
like these things that you know hey
you're you're you're off to do these
things you're an adult now
you know
live on your own all this [ __ ]
the people out there they don't give a
[ __ ] a teacher
doesn't [ __ ] care what happened to
you they can't your assignment
it was not turned in at the time i told
you it was [ __ ] supposed to be termed
there you see what i'm saying even if
you care there's nothing you can do
about it
there's nothing that like my acting
teacher used to say family dead family
killed in the fire terrible we got to
shoot
we gotta she got it the show must go out
you have to hear that you have to hear
those things yes if someone didn't say
that to me like my uh shout out shout
out chip children my anger management
teacher my third one uh when i when i
told him i said yeah man ain't got no i
don't have any how many confidence
because you know the way my
my stepfather would treat me and stuff i
didn't i don't have any confidence you
know
and he laughed
he goes what
it was your confidence
it was never his yeah he's never there
you go it's all yours who are you
talking about he goes he goes because
you you with him right now you
he was so he was so [ __ ] real with me
he was so [ __ ] bring up somebody
bring up ronnie
who ronnie lot who's that football
player yeah
shout out to ronnie lott now now try to
bring up a picture of him with this
thing [ __ ] with his finger yeah
ronnie lot would knock himself out he
hit people so hard
see that finger hey
ronnie lot
there was a playoffs might have been the
super bowl i can't remember that's not
him no no might have been playoffs might
have been super bowl i don't know either
way they said your finger is so [ __ ]
up that we're going to put in a cast
you're not going to be able to catch his
safety um free safety like we're not
going to be able to really figure out he
goes like this he goes
because because it's broken so badly we
have to just we have to rebrake and put
it on and he goes like this he goes
cut it off
and they're like what and he goes
cut it off i can't have it in the way we
got to win this game
so they cut that [ __ ] off that's
ronnie locke
so must go home
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's how it is and i'm not saying like
uh
i remember i remember uh
there was someone i was talking to gosh
i can't remember it was it was right
after i had this like was it revelation
is that the word i'm looking for yes
i've had this revelation about all that
[ __ ]
and
someone was and i was actually
comfortable to talk about my story you
know talk about my past
and uh someone's like man [ __ ] like
like like don't you you just have all
this kind of hate for him huh and i was
like
actually i don't no i was like i don't
at all and they're like what like like
that man [ __ ]
you know did they treated you this way
blah blah all this [ __ ] and i was like
no i don't know i guess it's useless
yeah because and i realized how useless
it [ __ ] was because there's honestly
no [ __ ] forward motion
with with that there's like there's no
way zero there's zero you get to be
right you gotta be right in you get to
be right and and
stagnant yeah in a [ __ ] stagnant pond
right
what do you got chin
i thought you're going somewhere
i know i thought i thought yeah i
thought
i just get i just get [ __ ] pumped up
yeah because i'm a singer i was a great
combo hey
this is great i love it dude yeah i love
talking to you yeah it was great you're
one of my favorite people oh wait thank
you you're one of mine too ah [ __ ]
thank you brian
so dave chappelle was recently
performing at the hollywood bowl last
night and a attacker actually came up on
stage and tried to tackle him and i
guess he had a fake gun on him well
there's a gun that shoots knives yeah
that shoots knife
but
it actually did not hurt dave chappelle
and there's actually footage of the man
being strong like wielded over on a
journey afterwards and his arm was
[ __ ] up like a flamingo
because dave chappelle said that him who
was the rhymes
jamie ross and jeff ross had all like
stomped him out well those guys didn't
but the security i think did you see
this i love how hollywood work is this a
video cat or something joe so
i mean and then dave got back on stage
it goes it was a trans woman oh yeah
here's some more video of that suspect
being loaded into an ambulance there uh
police don't have any motive he was
taken to the hospital police say the
weapon he used was a replica gun that
fires knife blades here's some more
video of that suspect being loaded into
an ambulance there people were there as
well he came on stage after the incident
and even cracked a joke apparently
asking was that will smith
wait so um
how did he [ __ ] get in
the hollywood bowl
with that
weapon i don't know probably there
weren't i don't know probably that's
what's that that's what's crazy to me
look at that [ __ ] arm yeah
right well he's a dick yeah people were
saying it looks like thompson girl when
he tried to dunk the box oh and his
[ __ ] arm was looking yeah
damn
he didn't say motive or anything like
that they haven't come out with any
crazy dude just some yeah people are
trying to draw it to the fact that there
was backlash with dave chappelle and his
trans jokes but there it isn't confirmed
yeah i i don't want to go off guys i
don't want to go off since mentally yeah
yeah when you're that famous and you
have that many people there's going to
be a crazy person who's going to do
something else there's actual footage of
him getting tackled i don't like
watching it because did he get did dave
chappelle didn't fall though right i
think he did tumble the van but you'll
see ladies and
for hip-hop gentlemen
[Applause]
but that was that was a tackle yeah that
was a tackle well he sucked at that
tackle
well [ __ ] that guy yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah would have been good if he
hey uh blac chyna lost her defamation
suit against the kardashians oh
completely i know kim won her like
little section but i didn't know all
right i don't know
brian how did you know i just saw it oh
so the beauty brand ulta beauty is
currently facing a lot of backlash
because they sent out an email promoting
kate spade uh david spade's uh
sister
beauty brand and the email said come
hang with kate spade
and i'm guessing people
it was a poor choice of words dummy
however i don't think that was the
intent but it is a terrible thing to
write oh my god so they are currently
apologizing to everybody saying we guys
misspoke we didn't have that in mind
while we were writing out our promotions
well this was davis bay's sister i think
yeah
by uh marriage i believe by marriage
uh but also they wrote that yeah they
said come hang with kate spade and they
were promoting her brand yeah
but they did not take into account oh
well what happened with her sometimes
things happen
things happen i don't think they meant
to do it oh no that was important
whoever did that and gave the okay for
it ain't gonna know several people
there's no way now
god damn
all right weird in the uk there was a
man who lost his penis because there was
a bacterial infection that made his dick
turn black and it eventually died
he then went to the doctor he was trying
to figure out how can i have a penis
like i want to live my life as a man
with a penis so
they spent six years artificially
growing another penis on his left arm
and it stayed there until it was fully
that's [ __ ] incredible dude i guess
groan i don't know what the term would
be but why don't after a [ __ ] oh come on
after six years he had it surgically
removed from his left arm and put in
place of where his penis should be so
now he has a fully intact penis that was
growing on his legs so they did it from
his arm
took that off and put it where it's
supposed to be and right now it is up
and at it it's working he also asked the
doctors that he wanted it to be six
inches
that's amazing
right
he did say that usually he hides it but
on occasion like he
parts he can get a boner
uh i don't know if he could get a boner
while i was on his left no i'm talking
about like now
now i believe so i believe it's fully
functioning now that's the new that is
the [ __ ] new
um
frontier that's crazy you reach out to
your foot though your left arm i don't
know tissue regeneration i guess that is
something but he gives great easy the
[ __ ] this is the scar that's where it
used to be that's amazing i like how
he's pulled into the picture just like
that [ __ ] amazing
they made him put his fist on his chin
like that and just [ __ ] that's
incredible good for him he has a b he
has a dick again well they did that with
ears they've done that with bladders um
they they do it they spray cells on it
they create like a scaffolding i guess
and then they spray cells shout out to
him for one to go six inches
yeah well
he could have been uh you know he could
have been greedy maybe it could have
been just like a weird thing for him to
have like a eight inch dick on his left
arm it might have been like a lot to
carry around yeah
arm's kind of heavy
god damn there you go
so this is an update to the mighty ducks
actor shawn waist we talked about him a
few months ago russell i love russell
yeah we talked about him a few months
ago about how he was found during his
the height of his drug addiction issues
yeah he's on the road to recovery he
actually recently booked a film role for
jesus revolution movie so he's a working
actor again which is oh wow he also ran
into russell peters where he actually
thanked him saying like oh you gave me
twenty dollars once behind a starbucks
and i remembered it i just want to say
thank you russell peters then offered
him a 10 minute spot and now she's got
to russell
yeah yeah so he's just getting all these
new opportunities
that was him he was like russell peters
is such a [ __ ] good guy damn
good for sean weiss
not good for him all right there you go
good good current events man yeah
all righty what do i have here
oh this is colby clemson's
tooth
we all know that moz is all sucker
punched him yeah yeah that would piss me
the [ __ ] off
being sucker punched
hell yeah yeah tooth broken [ __ ] that
man
i'm friends with uh
maz vidal's lawyer okay
that's interesting so he'll he's not
gonna he'll be fine he'll be fine he's
not gonna go to jail but
he's yeah i mean a civil suit's a
different kid yeah
they're saying it's a full looks
mozzie dolls team people are saying
that's fake uh mazda's team because
kobe's claiming claiming that it's like
a ninety five thousand hundred thousand
dollar watch and they're saying it's not
and that was damaged during the
alternative during the altercation so we
found out i'll break come on there you
go that's my my buddy yeah
oh okay um uh but we found out no amy
judd died recently i think it was like
two days ago and then she was dealing
with mental illness for quite some time
and suicidal thoughts so the family
actually said that she did die by
suicide but they didn't give details and
she was like seven in her 70s yeah 75
yeah um
she's a country singer the judds yep
her
other daughters ashley judd who's the
actress yep
well i'm not so sure that i the whole
family which one is [ __ ] the left the
older yeah okay yeah she's so cute look
at her yeah 75 that's some good surgery
uh it's tough i don't know i i uh you
know it's like
it's a weird thing when you are
who was i talking to about this where
it's like you can pretend the truth
isn't there for just so long oh god you
can keep like tightening your face and
doing all the stuff and creating a lot
of noise but
the truth is just gonna wait with a
fedora and a cigar yes
how long are we going to do this then
just take your time i'll be here window
no oh really that's awesome yeah keep
going yeah
eventually you visually exhaust yourself
the marketplace doesn't lie and you you
doesn't lie oh oh [ __ ] that's actually
just actually judd but she changed
that's not matter they killed herself
though no no no no no i don't know how
she judy is yeah i just didn't realize
so cute she was younger she was
still live yeah exactly but she changed
her face a lot this is kind of more like
what she looks like right now
well instead of brian callan so you know
[Laughter]
you know sometimes
all right this was pretty crazy this is
uh
we watch this do we yep when
it's the guy that's getting uh doing the
changes
yeah and he's just so calm
yeah yeah
we did watch it uh [ __ ] or china
[ __ ]
china
apparently they're losing millions of
dollars because the chinese government
wanted them to remove the statue of
liberty from the movie but they wouldn't
do it
the chinese
why because i don't know because uh
because it's pro-american brian
mentioned like they wanted him to change
what the oh they didn't want because
we didn't shoot the scene yeah there you
go they had to rewrite the entire scene
which is a big problem in the movie
you know but yeah the chinese are um
yeah
very uh guarded of their national
identity if you study chinese history
you realize that they've been on the
[ __ ] end of the stick for a long time
yeah and people have humiliated china
and treated china like second-class
citizens
in this country and in china the british
did it the americans did it to a lot
smaller degree but certainly the
japanese uh and uh
china was always treated very poorly and
um
you can understand the emotional
need for
you know why
yeah
and all that stuff they they they were
like we're never going to take this [ __ ]
again
we we let ourselves be weak and it's
never going to they're like not [ __ ]
up it's a very different mindset chinese
mindset very different mindset
and as a westerner i struggle sometimes
understanding it but having empathy for
it well yeah because i believe in
democracy and you know
and what the founding fathers created
and i think anybody else is wrong and i
would die for that
idea i mean the push comes to shove i
mean that's what you fight and die for
but that's me
thank you everybody you're welcome
what's the time yet right yeah that's
when brian dropped seriously
[Laughter]
all right the last one is
uh justin lin uh who's uh he he directed
a bunch of different fast and furious
he's not gonna direct it no but check it
out brian so
within ten days into production ten
eighteen productions he actually said
has to live no that's ten
reason why that's ten oh i'm sorry he's
putting 10 to 20 million dollars off the
table not taking it because of issues
with vin diesel he said vin diesel shows
up late uh doesn't show up in shape uh a
bunch of other stuff he's like
so he's like jesus only he makes films
yeah no so remember like the rock was
talking smack on i do vin diesel too so
it turns out it's been diesel it's vin
diesel it's not professional it's very
rich and doesn't care yeah yeah also
it's wedding it's
fast and furious
so if it
doesn't get made
bruh i liked up two
i liked the first uh actually i never
saw the my favorite one is the second
one when they added tyrese that's like
one oh tyrese
what would we do without pirates
who seems actually like a really cool
guy but what would we do without fast
and furious uh i don't watch him either
but
no i wait for the book to come out and
then i read
chappelle i love you i love you too it's
a good podcast this was great i wish you
all the best
i know i was like right there we got to
get dinner yeah
and um i'll be at stress factory this
weekend
[ __ ] joey diaz i'm excited um
and then uh washington dc dc comedy loft
let's get our tickets may 12th 13th 14th
brea
brea improv special taping may 19th i'll
see you then and then i'll be at the
west palm beach improv
at the end of may may 27 28 29.
guys i'm going out on my own
may 6th to may 7th uh this weekend i'll
be in san diego at uh grand opening
comedy club mic drop comedy club uh one
nighter in phoenix at stand up live
man if you guys don't show up in phoenix
that'd be really sad but uh june 24th to
25th in the summer time i'll be in uh
meatballs neighborhood east providence
rhode island at the comedy connection
thank you guys that gave me love on this
show
and thank you guys that
didn't give me love
you killed me i appreciate it man thank
you yeah i'm so happy you were part of
it thank you man appreciate it where's
your iron camera